>>> GOOD EVENING.
IN ABOUT 28 HOURS, WE WILL KNOW
SOMETHING IMPORTANT ABOUT FOUR
INDIVIDUALS AND PERHAPS
SOMETHING VITAL ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND POSSIBLE FUTURE OF THIS
DEMOCRACY.
KEEPING 'EM HONEST, IT'D BE NICE
IF THERE WERE A GENTLER WAY OF
FRAMING IT BUT IT'S HARD TO SEE
HOW BUZZ BECAUSE IN ABOUT 28
HOURS, WE WILL KNOW WHETHER
THESE FOUR, ALL FORMER PUBLIC
SERVANTS, HAVE ANY DEVOTION TO
THE LAWS AND INSTITUTIONS THEY
ONCE SWORE TO SERVE AND UPHOLD.
WHETHER THEY OWE THEIR
ALLEGIANCE ENTIRELY TO ONE MAN,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
FORMER-WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS, FORMER AIDES
AND ALLIES, DAN SCAVINO, STEVE
BANNON, AND CASH PATEL, HAVE
UNTIL TOMORROW NIGHT AT MIDNIGHT
TO ANSWER SUBPOENAS FROM THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY-6th
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ATTEMPT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION WHICH IS
THE EUPHEMISTIC PHRASE WE HAVE
ALL COME TO ACCEPT FOR AN
ATTEMPTED COUP.
IN A MOMENT, WE WILL HEAR FROM A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE MEANTIME, AS WE REPORTED
LAST NIGHT, DAN SCAVINO, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S TWITTER VOICE
IS IN THE WIND.
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELLING CNN HE
CAN'T BE FOUND TO RECEIVE THE
SUBPOENA.
AS FOR THE OTHER THREE, WE CAN'T
SAY TO WHAT DEGREE, IF ANY, THEY
HAVE COOPERATED WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
PERHAPS, THE CONGRESSMAN CAN
CLEAR THAT UP IN A MOMENT.
WHAT WE DOUGH NO IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TODAY SENT A MESSAGE
JUST AS PLAINLIWY AS THE ONES H
USED TO SEND WHEN HE WOULD ISSUE
THREATS TO POTENTIAL COOPERATORS
ORS HE CALLS THEM RATS.
AND WE SHOULD SAY WE GENERALLY
DO NOT AIR THE MAN'S RANTINGS AT
ALL, HOWEVER, IT IS A DIFFERENT
STORY WHEN THOSE RANTINGS SHOW
HIS RETROSPECTIVE SUPPORT FOR
THE LAST COUP ATTEMPT AND
SUGGEST HIS EAGERNESS FOR
ANOTHER.
NOW, HERE IS THE STATEMENT HE
RELEASED.
QUOTE, THE UNSELECT COMMITTEE OF
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS AND TWO VERY
WEAK AND PATHETIC RINOs SHOULD
COME TO THE CONCLUSION AFTER
SPENDING MANY MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THE REAL
INSURRECTION HAPPENED NOVEMBER
3rd.
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, NOT
ON JANUARY 6th, WHICH WAS A DAY
OF PROTESTING THE FAKE ELECTION
RESULTS.
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
BUT IT ALSO MIGHT BE A MESSAGE
TO THOSE FOUR WHO ARE DUE TO
COMPLY WITH THE COMMITTEE.
IN SHORT, RESIST.
OF COURSE, THERE IS NO WAY OF
KNOWING HIS MOTIVES.
PERHAPS, HE WAS SIMPL SIMPLY JE
MIKE PENCE'S REMARKS THE OTHER
DAY, AS ABSURD AS THEY WERE,
GRABBED THE SPOTLIGHT FOR ABOUT
24 HOURS.
>> I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE DAY IN
JANUARY.
THEY WANT TO USE THAT ONE DAY TO
TRY AND DEMEAN THE -- THE -- THE
CHARACTER AND INTENTIONS OF 74
MILLION AMERICANS WHO BELIEVED
WE COULD BE STRONG AGAIN AND
PROSPEROUS AGAIN AND SUPPORTED
OUR ADMINISTRATION IN 2016 AND
IN 2020.
>> I DON'T KNOW FOR A FACT.
I THINK HE PRACTICES THOSE
THINGS.
I THINK HE PRACTICES THE WHOLE
STEELY LOOK.
THE WHOLE KIND OF SHOULDER
WIGGLE.
THE WHOLE, LIKE, PENCE THING.
JUST A GUESS.
THAT'S THE GUY THAT RIOTERS SAID
THEY WANTED TO KILL.
LITERALLY, KILL HIM.
HANG HIM.
THAT VIDEO OF HIM BEING RUSHED
TO SAFETY, OF COURSE, THANKS TO
THE SECRET SERVICE, HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS, TOO.
BUT HE IS SO COMPROMISED BY HIS
FEALTY TO HIS FORMER MASTER, SO
DESPERATE TO BE PRESIDENT,
HIMSELF, HE'S GOTTEN SUCH A
LITTLE TASTE OF IT BEING VICE
PRESIDENT THAT HE IS TRYING TO
EXCUSE THE WHOLE AFFAIR.
JUST ONE DAY IN JANUARY.
THAT'S THE LESSONS HE'S LEARNED
APPARENTLY AND WE WILL SEE
TOMORROW IF THE PEOPLE
SUBPOENAED ARE READING FROM THE
SAME SCRIPT.
PROBABLY ARE.
IT'S BEHAVIOR NOT SEEN SINCE --
WELL, I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW, DAYS
OF STALIN?
AND HIS CROWD OF TOADYING
MEDIOCRITIES?
NEVER SEEN IT HERE REALLY, NOT
EVER, UNTIL NOW.
DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME.
LAST NIGHT I SPOKE WITH FIONA
HILL.
SHE IS A STUDENT AND HISTORIAN
OF RUSSIA AND THE SOVIET UNION.
AND SHE WORKED IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SHE SEES THE DANGER.
>> A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PATH
THAN WE HAVE BEEN ON FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL HUNDRED YEARS SINCE
OUR INDEPENDENCE.
WE ARE BACK ON THE PATH TO
TYRANNY AND I DON'T SAY THAT
LIGHTLY BECAUSE ONCE YOU GET
SOMEONE WHO HAS NO REAL RESPECT
FOR THE INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILT OVER HUNDREDS OF
YEARS, THAT HAVE BEEN LAID DOWN
IN THE CONSTITUTION AND ONLY
THINKS ABOUT THEMSELVES, THEN WE
HAVE FORGOTTEN WHAT THIS COUNTRY
WAS ABOUT.
>> ON THE ROAD TO TYRANNY.
JOINING US NOW, CONGRESSMAN
PETER, DEMOCRAT OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBER OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BEING WITH US.
DO YOU -- DO YOU BELIEVE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ALLIES WHOM
YOU'VE SUBPOENAED WILL ACTUALLY
COMPLY BY TOMORROW'S DEADLINE?
>> WELL, WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT
IT'S EVERY AMERICAN'S
OPPORTUNITY AND THEIR DUTY TO
RESPOND TO A SUBPOENA LIKE THIS.
AND TO -- AND TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THAT'S ALL WE'VE SOUGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING.
AND WE FEEL THAT IF SOMEONE
WANTED TO BE PATRIOTIC AND PUT
THE CONSTITUTION FIRST, THEY
WOULD DO JUST THAT.
>> BUT YOU KNOW THE TRACK RECORD
OF -- IN TRUMP WORLD, I MEAN,
THEY HAVE PROVEN THAT NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO SUBPOENAS FROM THE
HOUSE ACTUALLY WORKS.
IT ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE -- IT -- IT WAS A NORM
THAT WAS FOLLOWED THAT PEOPLE
WOULD REPLY TO SUBPOENAS BUT IT
TURNS OUT, THE HOUSE DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE THE -- THE POWER TO
ENFORCE THEM.
>> WELL, THAT'S TRUE.
UM, IN PRIOR TIMES.
AND I THINK THAT WE'LL SEE.
LET'S SEE THEIR LEVEL OF
COMPLIANCE, AND THEN WE'LL SEE
WHAT THE SELECT COMMITTEE DOES
FROM THERE.
BUT WE HAVE OPTIONS.
WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
THAT'S BEEN REPORTED, BOTH,
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL OPTIONS.
AND WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHO HAS AN OPEN LINE OF
COMMUNICATION WITH US.
AND SO, WE FEEL THAT -- THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO -- TO
COMPEL THEM AT SOME POINT.
>> CAN YOU SAY IF ANY OF THE
PEOPLE YOU HAVE SUBPOENAED
HAVE -- I MEAN, HAVE YOU BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE SOME OF THEM?
HAS DAN -- HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
SERVE DAN SCAVINO?
BECAUSE ALL THE REPORTING WE HAD
WAS THAT AS OF NOW, HE HAS NOT
BEEN SERVED.
>> I'VE SEEN THAT REPORTING, AS
WELL.
AND WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROPER STEPS AND I'M NOT GOING
TO GET INTO ALL THE
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS AND -- AND
MAYBE WE NEED TO, YOU KNOW, LOOK
IN DAN SCAVINO'S MOM'S BASEMENT
FOR HIM.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE'LL -- WE'LL DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
UM, AND WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
HELP IN ORDER TO -- TO
FACILITATE THAT.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT CRIMINAL
OPTIONS.
WHAT KIND OF -- I MEAN, ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE?
AND WHAT -- WHAT WOULD THAT --
HOW WOULD THAT WORK?
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE TOOLS FOR
NONCOMPLIANCE.
THE COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
A VOTE AND THE HOUSE WOULD
ULTIMATELY HAVE TO MAKE A VOTE
TO SEND SOMETHING TO DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
WHAT WE'VE SAID AND WHAT THE
CHAIRMAN HAS SAID VERY CLEARLY
IS THAT THOSE ARE OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE.
BUT LET'S STEP BACK.
LET'S WAIT FOR THE DEADLINE BOTH
FOR MATERIAL AS WELL AS FURTHER
TESTIMONY TO COME BEFORE US.
ONCE THOSE DEADLINES LAPSE, THEN
THE COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE WILL --
WILL LOOK AT THE ALTERNATIVES
AND -- AND TAKE ACTION THAT'S
ACCORDINGLY.
>> UM, CNN IS REPORTING THAT THE
FORMER-NUMBER TWO OFFICIAL AT
THE TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
RICHARD DONOGHUE, SAT FOR AN
INTERVIEW WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
THIS PAST FRIDAY.
CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS MAKING PROGRESS.
THAT THERE ARE STAFF-LEVEL
MEETINGS AND INTERACTIONS THAT
ARE INFORMAL AS WELL AS
INTERVIEWS THAT ARE TAKING PLACE
THROUGHOUT THE MONTH.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS.
MEMBERS ARE ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS.
AND OUR ULTIMATE GOAL HERE IS TO
PRODUCE A REPORT THAT LAYS OUT
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
5th AND JANUARY 6th AND THE
EVENTS THAT LED UP TO THAT.
THAT'S OUR GOAL.
THAT'S OUR FOCUS.
AND -- AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE.
>> WE JUST LEARNED THE FACEBOOK
WHISTLE-BLOWER WILL BE MEETING
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AS SOON AS
TOMORROW.
HAS SHE PROVIDED INFORMATION TO
YOUR COMMITTEE?
WHAT DO YOU HOPE TO LEARN FROM
HER?
>> I'M AWARE OF THAT REPORTING,
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
SHE INDICATED SHE WAS GOING TO
COME AND TALK TO THE COMMITTEE
WHILE SHE WAS ON CAPITOL HILL
EARLIER TODAY.
SO, YOU KNOW, LET'S -- I'LL
ALLOW THOSE CONVERSATIONS, YOU
KNOW, TO HAPPEN.
AND LET'S SEE WHAT CAN COME OF
IT.
LIKE I SAID, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF -- OF MEETINGS AND --
AND DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE BEING
HAD.
SOME AT THE STAFF LEVEL.
UM, AND SOME INVOLVING MEMBERS
AND INVESTIGATORS THAT ARE MORE
FORMAL.
AND SO, WE HAVE THESE TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO US AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MEET WITH ANYONE
WHO HAS INFORMATION OR SEEKS
TO -- TO PROVIDE US INFORMATION
THAT CAN HELP US IN ULTIMATELY
PRODUCING A REPORT THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE FACTS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN, AGAIN.
>> JUST LASTLY, I'M WONDERING,
YOU KNOW, WE -- I REALLY STOPPED
READING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S,
YOU KNOW, STATEMENTS THAT --
THAT THEY PUT OUT.
THIS ONE DID SORT OF RISE TO THE
TOP OF THE CESSPOOL OF
MAR-A-LAGO AND I SAW IT AND WE
MENTIONED IT TONIGHT.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE PRESIDENT
SAYING THE REAL INSURRECTION WAS
ELECTION DAY, I -- I KNOW, YOU
KNOW, THAT THE BAR HAS BEEN
LOWERED SO LOW FOR THIS PERSON.
BUT, YOU KNOW, TO THINK THAT A
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS CALLING AN ELECTION
DAY THAT WAS ACTUALLY WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC.
MORE PEOPLE COMING OUT THAN
EVER, BEFORE.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
VOTING.
IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS DID VERY WELL, ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
JUST THE PRESIDENT LOST.
THE IDEA THAT HE IS CALLING THAT
THE REAL INSURRECTION -- WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT HIS HOMELAND -- HIS OWN
HOMELAND SECURITY DEPARTMENT
SAID WAS -- WAS A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
UM, AND HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL AT
THE TIME SAID -- SAID THE SAME
THING.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST SO
DETACHED FROM REALITY BUT I
THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC SEES
RIGHT THROUGH THIS.
THEY KNOW THE LIES AND THE
DECEPTION THAT -- THAT -- THAT
HE STOKES TO -- TO PURSUE.
AND -- AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE AND
DIFFICULT BUT IT SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS GOING TO DO
HERE BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEPARATE
FACT FROM FICTION.
AND CLEARLY, THERE IS A LOT OF
FICTION THAT COMES OUT OF -- OUT
OF HIS FORMER TWEETS AND HIS
CURRENT -- HOWEVER HE PUTS THESE
STATEMENTS OUT.
BUT WE'RE GOING -- WE'RE GOING
TO GET TO THE TRUTH, AND WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT IN -- IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE IN AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE, AND WE
COMPEL FOLKS TO COME GIVE TH